I'm very fortunate to be alive
we all fell on the floor because we
didn't want to get shot and we lay there
on the floor for about 15 minutes and
then at some point everyone started
getting up and running away we ran
across the room and I threw myself
across the barrier and I went through
the emergency exit and then I ran for
about two minutes on the streets until I
found an open door to some building and
I hid in somebody's apartment
I saw people on the floor so people
probably dead and I I wish I could help
somebody but I was I was thinking about
saving my life and it's it's really hard
to get rid of those images because they
keep popping up in my head
these people and light like me they're
innocent they didn't do any bad to
anybody and they're not to blame for the
political issues that exist in the world
you